where does the book come from people
have been thinking about that for a long
time how do you begin how do you get
into it I would say that if you're if
you're not finding this happen somewhat
spontaneously you probably shouldn't be
doing this
activity I mean that a lot of people say
I want to be a writer and you say well
what do you want them right and they say
I don't know so for me I think it's not
a question of sitting around wondering
what I'm going to write it's a question
of sitting around wondering which of the
far-fetched and absurd ideas I'm
actually going to try to tackle
sometimes I think I should be a lot
safer and less risk-taking and stick to
somebody or something a little bit more
a little bit more manageable but those
aren't the things that appeal to me
unfortunately I wish I had a formula I
wish I had a way of proceeding that
would be kind of noble this is what
chapter one is always like and this is
what Chapter two is always like but it
isn't I just have to plunge into it and
it's usually the one that I that the
voice of sanity and reason is telling me
not to write it's usually dot one that I
end up writing
entry is always a handheld object with a
point on one end so it's gonna be there
a pencil or a pen and then it is applied
to a flat substance of some kind which
is usually a piece of paper but could be
a piece of cardboard if I put the paper
or even my arm when things get really
bad
I think people should carry notebooks
with them at all times just for those
moments because there's nothing worse
than having that moment and finding that
you're unable to set it down except with
a knife on your leg or something you
actually don't want to do that so the I
recommend the paper and the pencil or if
you must some other stylus writing
device that provides a permanent record
of what you've just sent down when we
get a bit further into it I have to say
that I do love the sticky notes unlike
them I like the bedside notebook for
those thoughts that are so important at
about 12:00 midnight and then you wake
up in the morning and can't figure out
why you thought that so all of that goes
on and then do you know what a rolling
barrage is rolling barrage comes from
World War one and it's when you you run
forward and then crouch down and your
side fires over your head then you stand
up run forward and your siren fires over
your head again if you got the timing
wrong of course it's unfortunate so I
start typing on a computer now computers
were very helpful for me because I was
always a bad typist and a bad speller I
start typing up my handwritten text
while I'm still writing it at the back
so the rolling barrage of typing goes on
while the writing creeps forward along
the ground if you will
first of all there is no normal time and
that it takes me to write a novel it
very much depends on the length of the
novel and how well or badly it's going
and some of them have taken quite a long
time because I have started off on the
wrong foot I've gotten quite far down
the path and realized that I have to
change everything go back to the
beginning start again and that can
happen several times so that of course
takes up time some of them are quite
quick because you you've started off the
right way and then you can just roll
with it I don't know whether you've ever
done any whitewater canoeing or or
surfing but that can be an exhilarating
experience and that's when the wave is
going with you with whitewater canoeing
you actually want to go faster than the
water and with surfing you wanted to go
with it but when that doesn't happen it
can be very frustrating and take up a
lot of time
am I served not anymore dear not anymore
I would break my neck